that's right about the time of the day  where then HS and England publishes the  figures for the Italian people who've  succumbed to covert 19 let me share  those figures with you now there's a  story of fractional improvement but the  number is still huge  of course yesterday a number of people  in England that the that had died in at  twelve whose deaths had been recorded  and reported in 24 hour period  yesterday was 828 the figure today for  the previous 24 hours is 765 taking the  total of people who have died from  coronavirus in England according to the  NHS to 7200 48 up from 6000 483 but of  course when it comes to planning when it  comes to thinking about as Cobra will be  this afternoon at the lockdown this is  very much driving through the rearview  mirror you're looking back at figures  that began even before the lockdown when  people maybe contracted this before then  taking a period of time to succumb to  the disease we'll be talking through  those numbers very soon